he national politics Europe is sometimes
accused of foot dragging and failing to
deliver for the layman our work at the
Eurogroup is proving this critics wrong
a months ago we agreed on the key
features of a five hundred and forty
billion safety net for the euro area
today we are poised to agree and further
advanced on all elements of this plan a
plan that protects us from the economic
fallout of this crisis an instrument to
finance work protection schemes a
pan-european guarantee to support firms
and an insurance for sovereigns today we
can make good on that promise and inject
these resources in our economies
leveling up the tools that each member
state has to fight this crisis that will
largely settle our response to the
emergency phase and laid the ground for
a strategic discussion on the recovery
the Euro group already agreed on a few
key features of this recovery fund the
Commission has identified clear
investment needs in its forecast and it
will put forward a proposal in the
coming weeks building on that we will
focus today on what should be the key
strategic priorities for the new plan in
key areas for coordination of national
policies we will also discuss how to
best design and target a recovery fund
in order to boost our national policies
and protect the single market